[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a proponer un reto cuando
terminéis de ver este vídeo id a la
cocina a abrir el frigorífico y os reto
a que encontréis algo que esté producido
fuera de vuestro país
si estáis en españa entonces son reto a
que encontréis algo que esté producido
fuera de la unión europea
[Música]
cuidados en un detalle vuestro teléfono
móvil está hecho en más de 20 países
distintos
vuestra ropa está hecha en china o en
bangladesh y es probable que hasta la
empresa en la que trabaja sea de otro
país es normal verdad vivimos en un
mundo globalizado sin embargo la comida
o más concretamente la agricultura es
todavía un mundo hiper protegido de
hecho no os equivoquéis las guerras
comerciales no son un invento de donald
trump en realidad el sector primario
lleva décadas inmerso en una guerra fría
y por eso no es nada raro encontrarse de
vez en cuando con titulares como este
[Música]
comienza una guerra comercial en el
mundo agrícola los precios de la soja y
la carne de cerdo caen en picado o este
otro la unión europea reduce los
aranceles para acabar con la guerra de
las bananas pero no sólo hablamos de
aranceles en realidad los aranceles son
solo un arma más para atacar a los
mercados extranjeros pero hay otras
igual o más letales por ejemplo eeuu se
gasta cada año más de 20 mil millones de
dólares en subvenciones y ayudas a la
agricultura os parece mucho pues
esperado un momento porque la unión
europea se gasta muchísimo más en este
caso hablamos de una suma equivalente a
72 mil millones de dólares y os
preguntaréis qué tienen que ver las
subvenciones con las guerras comerciales
pues mucho
por ejemplo este brick de leche que veis
en la pantalla cuesta unos 60 céntimos
de euro en un supermercado de españa de
esos 60 céntimos 30 van para el ganadero
que tienen las vacas pero en realidad
este ganadero ganaría unos 44 céntimos
por cada brick de leche porque la unión
europea le paga una subvención de 14
céntimos por cada litro de leche que
vende
gracias a esta subvención el ganadero
puede vender baratos sin perder dinero y
eso explica que por ejemplo en europa
nadie compre azúcar africano o que
incluso en áfrica los productores
europeos o estadounidenses les quiten
cuota de mercado a los productores
locales sin embargo las cosas podrían
empezar a cambiar y no en este caso el
abanderado del libre mercado no es eeuu
ni japón ni australia hablamos de la
mismísima unión europea
enmanuel macrón rompe el tabú francés
sobre los subsidios a granjeros para que
os hagáis una idea el hecho de que un
presidente de la república francesa
cuestione las ayudas europeas a la
agricultura es como si un hipster
cerrará su cuenta de instagram algo
nunca visto durante años la llamada
política agraria común también conocida
como la pac era uno de los pilares de la
unión europea pero las cosas podrían
cambiar mucho más rápido de lo que nos
pensamos así que la pregunta es de
verdad de europa está dispuesta a
liberalizar su agricultura veremos el
fin de las guerras comerciales de los
alimentos y lo que es más importante es
eso una buena o una mala noticia hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
para qué sirve la pac vamos a imaginar
que tenemos un cultivo de trigo en
valladolid en españa que por cierto es
la región de donde yo soy oriundo
[Música]
recogemos la cosecha y la vamos a vender
al mercado la última vez que fuimos lo
vendimos por vamos a decir unos
doscientos euros por tonelada así que
parece razonable que esta vez lo
podremos vender por un precio similar
verdad pues bien resulta que en este
momento el trigo cotiza muy por debajo
de ese precio y que sólo nos pagan
ciento setenta euros por toneladas
[Música]
pues esta es la realidad a la que se
enfrentan todos los agricultores del
mundo por contrastar el precio de un
iphone es el mismo ahora que hace un año
sin embargo tanto el trigo como el
petróleo como el maíz o como cualquier
otra materia prima puede cambiar de un
día para otro
[Música]
y os preguntaréis por qué pues porque
las materias primas también conocidas
como commodities son iguales en todas
partes seguro que ninguno de vosotros
sabría decirme de dónde viene el trigo
con el que se hace el pan que habéis
comido hoy verdad pasa lo mismo con el
zumo de dinosaurio con el que se hace la
gasolina que ponemos en el coche no
sabemos de dónde viene ni nos importa
solo queremos que sea lo más barata
posible la diferencia es que hay muy
pocos países que produzcan un mmo de
dinosaurio y sin embargo campos de trigo
o de patatas los hay en todas partes y
va hasta que haya una buena cosecha en
tal sitio para que el precio caiga en
picado
a eso hay que sumarle el tiempo si un
año llueve poco o llueve demasiado o
tenemos un invierno más frío de lo
normal todo nuestro negocio se viene
abajo en otras palabras que en principio
parece imposible que un agricultor pueda
sacar algún beneficio
nos parece sin embargo necesitamos
agricultura porque por desgracia el
petróleo y los iphones no se pueden
comer así que qué podemos hacer para
poder tener alimentos y a la vez que los
agricultores no se mueran de hambre os
puede parecer una tontería pero este es
uno de los problemas más complicados de
la política y la economía
y aquí es donde entra la política
agraria común también conocida como la
pac
[Música]
este es el sistema con el que la unión
europea' protege a los agricultores
hablar de la pac es hablar de uno de los
pilares de la unión europea está entre
nosotros desde los años sesenta es decir
antes mucho antes que el euro el espacio
schengen es más a que no adivina quién
fue el padre político de esta política
agraria común exacto el por entonces
presidente de francia nuestro amigo
charles de gaulle
[Música]
una nación no tiene amigos sólo
intereses charles de gaulle si lleváis
tiempo suscritos a visual político ya
sabéis que de gol no era precisamente un
amigo del libre mercado ni en general de
nadie que no fuera el mismo así que
cuando francia entró en el mercado común
europeo lo que luego pasaría a ser la
unión europea de gol puso una condición
vale
nosotros entramos pero tenéis que
prometer nos que nadie va a hacerle la
competencia a nuestros granjeros y así
es como nació la pac una política tan
intervencionista que a su lado pablo
iglesias parece warren buffett
[Música]
básicamente para compensar las posibles
pérdidas de los agricultores cuando
bajan los precios de las materias primas
europa les da dinero contante y sonante
por ejemplo si tenemos un establo con
vacas en españa' bruselas nos va a dar
todos los años una cantidad de dinero
por cada vaca que tengamos y si queremos
comprar una nueva máquina para ordeñar
más moderna que nos permita ser más
productivos
bruselas también tiene toda clase de
ayudas de esta forma no solo nos
garantizamos que los agricultores puedan
sobrevivir a las subidas y bajadas de
los precios sino que también
también nos aseguramos que ningún
africano ni latinoamericano ni asiático
pueda vender nada en territorio europeo
y como os podéis imaginar todas estas
ayudas suponen mucho pero que mucho
dinero
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en los años
90 la pac representaba el 80 por ciento
de todo el presupuesto de la unión
europea y hoy en día que europa se ha
vuelto más grande y tiene más
competencias hablamos del 40 por ciento
ya que no adivináis qué país es el que
más dinero recibe exacto francia pero
esperad un momento porque la cosa no se
queda aquí
europa cuenta con otras dos armas
secretas para evitar que bajen los
precios de las materias primas las
cuotas y los aranceles
por ejemplo para evitar que bajará el
precio de la leche
europa ponía un límite a la producción
de cada país es decir que si tú tenías
una granja con vacas en españa solo
podías vender un máximo de litros y por
supuesto quién era el principal
beneficiado de estas políticas exacto el
país que las inventó francia como os
podéis imaginar esta política de cuotas
generaba toda clase de problemas entre
los estados miembros y por eso europa ha
terminado por retirarla para disgusto de
los franceses
[Música]
el fin de las cuotas de leche europeas
marcan una nueva era para el sector en
francia y por supuesto también tenemos
los aranceles que son como balas de
francotirador para evitar que se cuelen
productos extranjeros en el suelo
europeo
por ejemplo imaginad que somos un
agricultor argentino y producimos café
pues bien si queremos vender nuestros
granos de café crudos es decir tal cual
salen de la planta sin procesar europa
nos los compras sin poner ningún arancel
por qué pues porque casi ningún país
europeo cultiva granos de café
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ahora bien si queremos vender ese café
tostado y procesado tendremos que pagar
un arancel especial del 75 por ciento
porque pues por que europa si tiene
fábricas que procesan el café y como os
podéis imaginar no les gusta la
competencia y ya se lo que estáis
pensando o esa malvada unión europea que
castiga a los países del tercer mundo
esos burócratas de bruselas que quieren
acabar con el libre comercio pues lo
cierto es que prácticamente todos los
países del mundo hacen lo mismo es más
en lo que aranceles se refiere europa es
una de las regiones más abiertas del
mundo
[Música]
en esta gráfica podéis ver los aranceles
de europa comparados con los de eeuu y
japón por ejemplo que aranceles tienen
en japón para el café procesado 20%
aranceles para los plátanos o las
bananas entre el 40 y el 50% y así suma
y sigue y que me decidir de eeuu pues
prácticamente igual casi ningún país
parece dispuesto a dejar que sus
agricultores compitan en igualdad de
condiciones con los del resto del mundo
sin embargo todo esto puede cambiar
porque ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los tiempos para el proteccionismo todos
los años europa se gasta más de 72 mil
millones de dólares en subvencionar a
sus agricultores pero como os podéis
imaginar no todos los países miembros
pagan la misma cantidad fijaos en la
gráfica aquí podéis ver cuáles son los
principales contribuyentes netos es
decir quienes pagan más de lo que
reciben
y oh sorpresa quién es el tercer mayor
contribuyente de la pac
efectivamente reino unido
justo el país que está a punto de
marcharse de la unión como os podéis
imaginar esto deja un agujero de 12 mil
millones de euros un agujero lo
suficientemente grande como para que
muchos propongan que el resto de los
estados miembros empiecen a pagar más
para mantener el mismo cast
[Música]
la comisión europea apremia a los países
miembros para que paguen más para el
presupuesto comunitario sin embargo casi
nadie está por la labor de pagar más en
un momento donde los partidos políticos
euroescépticos tienen más fuerza que
nunca ningún político quiere volver a su
país diciendo preparad la cartera que
ahora vamos a tener que contribuir más
por estar en la unión europea así que
esto es matemática pura y dura' si no
hay dinero para pagar las ayudas sólo
queda una opción
bruselas planea reducir con los pagos a
las granjas más grandes de europa
básicamente europa ha tenido que reducir
las ayudas directas a los agricultores y
han decidido empezar por los más ricos
que son supuestamente los que menos las
necesitan pero lo más sorprendente fue
el discurso de macrón todo el mundo en
europa se esperaría que francia saliera
a la palestra defendiendo que la pac
siguiera como ésta sin embargo más gran
tiene otras prioridades y esto significa
luz verde para poder seguir recortando
estas ayudas en el futuro
cada vez va siendo más habitual
encontrarse noticias como esta
la unión europea y méxico alcanzan un
nuevo pacto de libre comercio o esta
otra
[Aplausos]
la unión europea' se apresura para
promover el borrador del acuerdo de
libre comercio con japón subrayando los
beneficios que tendría para los
agricultores europeos es decir que muy
lentamente la unión europea está
reduciendo ayudas reduciendo aranceles y
acabando con esas cuotas de producción
de las que hablábamos antes y os
preguntaréis por qué pues aparte del
break si los políticos europeos se han
dado cuenta de dos cosas por un lado la
agricultura europea es ya mucho más
productiva que la de prácticamente
cualquier país del mundo en este otro
vídeo os hablábamos de como holanda es
el líder mundial en exportación de
patatas y tiene lo que podríamos llamar
el silicon valley de la tecnología
alimentaria pero no son los únicos las
exportaciones de alimentos no dejan de
crecer
es más estoy seguro de que los que veáis
este vídeo desde cualquier país de
latinoamérica podréis encontrar en
cualquier supermercado vino de ribera
del duero o queso camembert todos esos
son productos europeos que están dando
la vuelta al mundo en otras palabras que
europa ya no quiere proteger su mercado
sino todo lo contrario quieren hacer
pactos de libre comercio con todos los
países posibles para poder seguir
exportando y ya sé lo que os estaréis
preguntando ahora de verdad los
agricultores europeos se van a poner
contentos cuando dejen de recibir tantas
ayudas y tengan que competir en el
mercado internacional
[Música]
pues probablemente no pero seamos
honestos la agricultura ya no tiene el
peso político que tenía en los años 60
por ejemplo en la época de de gaulle
francia tenía a millones de personas
trabajando en la agricultura hoy en día
a duras penas llegan al 3% de la
población todo esto significa muchísima
menos presión política y muchísimos
menos votos y por si todo esto fuera
poco a quien diría es que votan todos
esos agricultores franceses
[Música]
los granjeros desencantados miran hacia
el epen exacto en términos generales los
mayores caladeros de votos de los
partidos euroescépticos están en las
zonas rurales las zonas más agrícolas
así que puestos a cortejar a votantes
las instituciones de la unión europea
prefieren prestar atención a la gente
que vive en las ciudades gente que ni
siquiera sabe a duras penas lo que es la
política agraria común
así que la pregunta es tiene futuro la
para que en europa o vamos a ver una
progresiva liberalización de la
agricultura hasta qué punto europa
podría contagiar al resto de países
veremos un día el fin de los aranceles
en el mundo de la alimentación
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y por supuesto no olvidéis
visitar nuestra página el patrón donde
no solamente podréis colaborar con
visual politics sino que además tendréis
acceso a contenido exclusivo y por
supuesto si es vuestra primera vez en
este canal suscribiros para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones os
ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]